So congratulations.
I'm impressed you made it so far.
You really learned a lot about SLAM.
You learned about the MAP, which is a sequence of coordinates,
and you learned about Localization--
and "L" and "M" are really important letters here.
The Simultaneous and the And are not that essential.
We put all of those into a big Matrix, Omega, and a vector, Xi.
And every time, we got some relative information between poses.
We carved out some stuff in here
or we measured something.
We added some stuff in here, and over here.
These were all just additions
and, as we now understand,
those implement the straightforward constraints
that come from the motion--the measurements.
And then the key thing was that you could solve,
with a simple piece of equation,
for the Path and the Map at the same time.
That was quite an amazing achievement.
So you've implemented this,
you've implemented your first SLAM algorithm.
That was way beyond anything I ever taught
students at Stanford in a single class.
Congratulations for doing this.
So this is the last, and final, class.
I'm going to output a challenge to everybody, briefly,
where you can write a Robot program
that puts most of the stuff we talked about together.
But, for now, congratulations for making it so far.
That is really impressive.